>> Jesse: LIBERAL CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR TO GAVIN NEWSOM WAGING
TOTAL WAR ON RED STATES.
THE LEFT-WING LEADER TRYING TO
MAKE THE CASE THAT WHAT AMERICA
REALLY NEEDS RIGHT NOW IS MORE
OF HIS STATE'S PROGRESSIVE
POLICY.
HE HAS BEEN BASHING REPUBLICAN
LEGISLATES FOUR WEEKS AND EVEN
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO MOVE TO
CALIFORNIA.
SPEAK OF FREEDOM IS UNDER ATTACK
IN YOUR STATE, REPUBLICAN
LEADERS ARE BANNING BOOKS,
MAKING IT HARDER TO VOTE,
RESTRICTING SPEECH IN
CLASSROOMS, EVEN CRIMINALIZING
WOMEN AND DOCTORS, I URGE ALL OF
YOU TO JOIN THE FIGHT OR JOIN US
IN CALIFORNIA, WE STILL BELIEVE
IN FREEDOM, FREEDOM OF SPEECH,
THE FREEDOM TO LOVE.
DON'T LET THEM TAKE YOUR
FREEDOM.
>> Jesse: HE APPEARS TO HAVE
AN EYE ON 2024 AND THIS COULD
HELP THEM DECIDE, HAS HIM
PERFORMING BETTER THAN
KAMALA HARRIS IN HYPOTHETICAL
2024 MATCHUPS.
I HEARD YOU GROWN OH, MY GOD AT
ONE POINT.
>> Judge Jeanine: I SAID GOSH.
>> Jesse: WHAT WERE YOU
REFERRING TO.
SPEAK ON THE FREEDOM IN
CALIFORNIA, I WAS IN CALIFORNIA
DURING COVID, IT WAS LOCKED
DOWN, IT WAS DEPRESSING, YOU
COULD NOT GO ANYWHERE OR DO
ANYTHING AND I WAS IN FLORIDA
LIKE A WEEK LATER WHEN NOBODY
KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON IN THE
NEED COMPARE THE MORTALITIES AND
THE DEATH BETWEEN FLORIDA, THIS
GUY SHOULD BE EMBARRASSED, HE IS
GOOD LOOKING AND IS HOPING THAT
SOME PEOPLE WILL VOTE FOR HIM
BECAUSE OF THAT, BUT AT THE SAME
TIME, WHY ARE YOU PICKING A
FIGHT WITH RON DeSANTIS?
YOU CANNOT COMPARE YOURSELF IN
THE NUMBERS, HE WANTS PEOPLE,
FLORIDIANS TO JOIN THE FIGHT,
THEY ARE LEAVING CALIFORNIA AND
IN DROVES TO GO TO FLORIDA.
IS HE STUPID?
AND NOW FLORIDA IS ONE OF THE
MAIN AREAS PEOPLE WANT TO MOVE
TO, AND ARREST MY CASE.
>> Jesse: WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND?
>> Jessica: I THINK HE IS VERY
CUTE TOO.
IT WAS AN INTERESTING TARGET.
I UNDERSTAND THAT HE WANTS TO
RUN IN 2024, AND GET ON THE
NATIONAL STAGE, BUT PICKING
FLORIDA IS A STRANGE CHOICE, I
THOUGHT IT MAY BE PICK UP
SOMETHING MORE REGIONALLY WHERE
YOU CAN SAY THIS IS NOT THAT FAR
AWAY COMING OUT OF A REALLY
RESTRICTIVE CAN COME HERE FOR A
BEAUTIFUL --
I KNOW NOT EVERYONE AGREES, BUT
SOME PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO LIVE
IN STATES WHERE ABORTION HAS
BEEN BANNED.
IT'S TRUE.
OKAY, IT'S JUST OBJECTIVELY
TRUE.
BUT GAVIN NEWSOM, WHERE THEY
TALKED ABOUT HIM A BIT, AND FROM
COLORADO, THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN EXECUTIVE POSITIONS OF
POWER WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
PRESIDENCY, ITS MANAGEMENT JOB,
AND PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
MANAGERS, SO MAYORS, GOVERNORS,
ET CETERA, SO IN THAT SENSE IT
MAKES SENSE TO ME AND THAT THEY
ARE MAKING A VERY AGGRESSIVE
CASE FOR A LIBERAL POLICY IS FOR
THIS EXCESSES THEY ARE SEEN AT
HOME, BECAUSE IF YOU'RE PUTTING
OUT AGAINST WHAT PEOPLE FEEL AND
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH JOE BIDEN
IT'S A SMART MOVE TO MAKE PEOPLE
SAY, OH, HE IS NOT OUT THERE AND
ADVOCATING FOR ANYTHING OR
DEFENDING US AND HER LIBERAL
WORLD ORDER AS YOU WOULD, SO I
THINK THAT'S WHAT IS GOING ON.
>> Jesse: DOESN'T COME ACROSS
AS A LITTLE CLUMSY THE WAY THAT
HE ROLLED OUT THIS CAMPAIGN
AGAINST FLORIDA?
>> Sandra: I WAS CRACKING UP
WHEN I SAW THE ACTUAL AD
CAMPAIGN TAKING ON
RON DeSANTIS CLAIMING FREEDOM
IS UNDER ATTACK.
I MEAN, ON THE SAME DAY WE ARE
LITERALLY IT HAS BEEN REVEALED
NOW THAT THE RED STATES ARE
WINNING THE POST-ECONOMIC
RECOVERY FROM THE PANDEMIC AFTER
BEING CRITICIZED FOR STAYING
OPEN, THEY WERE TAX HAVENS FOR
PEOPLE WHO WANTED TO FLEE THESE
HIGH TAX STATES, FLORIDA GOT ALL
OF THE --
THE NUMBER ONE STATE THE LEFT
WAS CALIFORNIA.
SO I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT HE IS
WORKING OFF OF.
SO THESE RED STATES, BY THE WAY
ARE THRIVING IN THE
POST-PANDEMIC ECONOMIC RECOVERY
AND THAT IS GOING TO WIN A LOT
OF VOTES COME MIDTERM ELECTIONS,
WATCH IT.
>> Jesse: GREG IT, DO YOU
UNDERSTAND THE MOVE HE IS
MAKING?
>> Greg: VERY HANDSOME, HIS
DISSENT SAYS EVERYTHING UNFAIR
ABOUT WHAT GENDER AND IT LOOKS,
IF YOU ARE HANDSOME, YOU KEEP
YOUR NOSE CLEAN COMING YOU CAN
GET ANYTHING YOU WANT IN LIFE.
IF YOU LOOK LIKE JERROLD NADLER
WE WOULD NOT BE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION.
>> Judge Jeanine: HE KEEPS
GETTING ELECTED.
>> Greg: CALIFORNIA IS A MESS,
BUT HE ISN'T.
HE IS DELICIOUS, THE ONLY REASON
WHY HE IS TAKEN SERIOUSLY AS A
CANDIDATE IS BECAUSE HE HAS A
HAIRLINE.
BUT JUST THINK ABOUT THIS, STEP
BACK ALL YOU FIBERS THAT HAVE
BEEN WATCHING THE SHOW FOR A
DECADE, IMAGINE IF HE GETS THE
NOMINATION RUN